le président de la république que
vendredi dernier était devant un
parterre de maires à souillac et parmi
les nombreuses choses dont il leur a
parlé il l'a expliqué qu' une meilleure
transparence de l'information
passé par je cite une levée progressive
de toute forme d'anonymat sur internet
alors est ce que c'est une bonne idée ou
pas d'interdire l'anonymat sur internet
je propose d'écouter une pour et 1
contre
celle qui est pur c'est rachida dati la
députée européenne et maire du 7e
arrondissement de paris les républicains
elle elle trouve que il ya trop de
choses qui se disent impunément sur
internet écouter
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné trop
c'est trop
vous pouvez pas vous prendre des
déferlement de haine par des gens qui
sont planqués c'est pas possible
au moins qu'on puisse se défendre si on
veut poursuivre aujourd'hui pour enlever
les masques sur les réseaux sociaux en
est un et vous c'est pas possible c'est
trop facile
c'est tellement facile rachida dati qui
était ce matin chez le confrère de
france info et puis voilà quelqu'un
maintenant qui est plutôt contre une loi
sur ce sujet ce qui est intéressant
c'est justement du gouvernement figurez
vous c'est moyen mais j'oublie qui est
le secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
dont qui est quand même supposé
connaître assez bien ce sujet il était
ce matin à sur rmc élu en gros il dit
une levée de l'anonymat ça sert à rien
parce que on attrape déjà ce qu'on a
besoin de trouver cette année c'est plus
de 500 d'entre eux qu'on a attrapé qu'on
a condamné dire que ne croyons pas que
parce que le pseudo est anonyme
on peut pas ensuite faire des poursuites
judiciaires mené une enquête et savoir
qui était derrière pourquoi allah n'est
pas levée l'anonymat je vous le dire
parce que pour ceux qui maîtrisent un
tout petit peu de ce groupe 2
microgrammes de technicité c'est
impossible c'est impossible monsieur
bourdin
si on disait demain sur twitter on lève
l'anonymat n'existe pas parce que les
gens ils iront sur twitter bis ils iront
ailleurs ils feront de choses ils seront
des fausses identités
une phrase pour ce pour saluer la
liberté de ton de bunia mahjoubi king en
gros s'oppose quand même frontalement à
ce que j'aime bien le président de la
république qui est supposé être son
patron jenny prades est inquiétant parce
vous êtes plutôt pour guy ou plutôt
contre cette levée de l'anonymat total
rencontre contre la lgv est totalement
content parce que je considère que
l'année
aujourd'hui comme le garant de la
liberté d'expression liberté
d'expression qui a quand même fait
l'objet de plusieurs lois liberticides
au cours des dernières années il faut
quand même avoir à l'esprit que
aujourd'hui si vous lever l'anonymat il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ne vont plus
pouvoir s'exprimer sur les réseaux
sociaux je pense notamment aux salariés
certaines entreprises ou aux
fonctionnaires qui ont quand même en
droit de réserve
imaginez donc que l'état est surveillée
les fonctionnaires sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'ils seraient rendus ce
qui serait possible en si s'il n'y avait
pas d'anonymat
et n'oublions pas que l'anonymat permet
aussi aux lanceurs d alerte de lancer
des alertes et à certaines personnes de
révéler des choses qu'elle ne pourrait
pas faire en l'absence d'un animal je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention à
ça et ayant aussi en mémoire pain ayons
aussi en tête que l'anonymat a toujours
existé quand on regarde les grands poufs
les sous l'ancien régime
ils étaient faits par des personnes
s'écrivait dans l'anonymat ou avec un
pseudonyme donc je pense que c'est
totalement illusoire et comme disait
d'ailleurs très bien sûr j'oublie
janvier exactement
merci je pense que c'est juste pas
possible parce que vous prenez prenons
un exemple simple
imaginons que tout le monde doivent
mettre son nom il y aurait des homonymes
donc ça pourrait poser des problèmes
donc en fait on aboutirait in fine et à
ce que tout le monde mettre sa photo
pour éviter les problèmes avec les ovnis
donc c'est juste impossible
moi je pense qu'il a tout à fait raison
il y a aujourd'hui une répression a
posteriori qui est possible vous pouvez
alors il faudrait peut-être la facilité
parce que c'est un petit peu complexe
mais on peut pas lever l'anonymat c'est
c'est juste pas possible d'attendre à sa
manière pour ou contre levée de
l'anonymat sur internet plutôt contre
aussi parce que viser l'anonymat c'est
ce vraiment se tromper de combat
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est pas
l'anonymat qui est le principal acteur
de la haine sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas ça qui permet si vous regardez
une plateforme qui se comporte de
manière plutôt civile prenons wikipedia
être elle fonctionne uniquement sur un
anonymat de ses contributeurs et je n'ai
pas vu d'appel au meurtre j'ai pas vu
d'incitation à la haine sur cette
plateforme ou en tout cas très peu
beaucoup moins que twitter ou facebook
aujourd'hui donc ça prouve bien que
c'est un problème de quatre formes que
les plates formes doivent régler en
interne et pas un problème d'anonymat
c'est très intéressant parce que moi
j'étais plutôt pour la levée de
l'anonymat
je ne supporte pas les gens qui envoient
des
des insultes courageusement cacher
derrière un pseudo mais vous fait
réfléchir benoît du moulin vous êtes
quoi vous pouvoir contre absolument
compte la levée de cet anonymat
tout d'abord parce que bon pour les
raisons qui viennent d'être appelés
d'ailleurs c'est très c'est très vrai ce
que vous dites c'est beaucoup plus le
format à mon avis de de twitter qui en
140 maintenant ça a doublé signe peut
permettre d'utiliser la parole comme un
comme un défouloir
c'est ça qui finalement fait qu'on a le
tweet facile mais c'est pas l'anonymat
en fait si vous lever l'anonymat qu'est
ce que j'allais vomir mahjoub il a dit
vous allez avoir un tweeter bis ou un
autre réseau social sur lequel les gens
vont se défouler et du coup twitter et
facebook ça va devenir un réseau
aseptisé lisse et les gens vont finir
par se retirer parce qu'on dira des
choses convenues on fera on dira même ce
qu'il faut pour pour le salarié mettra
ce qui convient aux patrons ça sera ça
sera le rôle de rôle de courtisans les
fonctionnaires bien sûr on a parlé il
fonctionnaires ils n'existeront plus là
ils ferment leurs comptes twitter alors
peut-être que c'est une stratégie pour
finalement couler facebook et twitter
dans ce cas là c'est très intelligent
parce qu'effectivement si vous faites ça
la voulez vous couler et tout le monde
ferme sont conquis jour là lors de toute
évidence vos arguments ne laisse pas
indifférent aux internautes puisque sur
twitter vous êtes 58% à être contre la
levée de l'anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux
scarano dit joliment enlevé l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux revient à
retirer le rideau de l'isoloir
l'anonymat permet de s'exprimer sans que
l'opprobre vous tombe dessus près dé
carbonée ce que vous rejoignez ce choeur
unanime à part aux jeunes voteront non
match du global fashion ou totalement
d'accord est ce qui a été dit ou jeu
plutôt contre la levée de l'anonymat
qu'ils s'impliquent totalement gossip
enfin c'est presque une question qui se
pose pas tellement elle n'est pas
applicable et je rejoins je vais pas
répéter les mêmes arguments il ya un
point qui m'intéressent là-dedans faille
il y en a deux il ya dans les raisons
pour lesquelles ça a été mis sur le sur
le tapis par le président de la
république il ya la question de la haine
il ya aussi la question des fausses
informations il y là et et là ça pose
une autre question qui est quelle est la
fonction des réseaux sociaux
est-ce que la fonction des réseaux
sociaux et que ne circule dessus que des
vraies informations
je suis désolé que non je suis comme
tout le monde je me désole du
déferlement de fenioux sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux mais les réseaux sociaux
ne sont pas un lieu où les ou par
essence des informations sont vérifiées
enfin autant au moins le rappeler si ça
peut servir à quelque chose donc le la
fonction des réseaux sociaux n'est pas
une information vérifiée s'est passé
c'est pas le but il y en a certainement
ces deux opinions des commentaires des
classes y en a près de 2 deuxième petit
point en revanche sur la question
parce que oui vous avez raison sur le
sur le la haine et les déferlements
d'accusation sous un masque anonyme
évidemment que c'est absolument
dégueulasse oui bien sûr et là la police
en revanche entre guillemets du d'une
aide doit être beaucoup mieux faites par
les images oublie de 10 par les états à
commencer par facebook twitter et autres
oui bien sûr qu'il faut en cas d'injures
raciales de de menaces demande
oui il faut bien l'espagne c'est pas les
opinions évident que c'est pas des
opinions mais un jour raciale attaque
homophobe
oui bien sûr qu'il faut y aller bien sûr
évidemment et vous pensez que vraiment
les pouvoirs publics ont les moyens
d'aller chercher tous ces gens le
fassent que google lui-même
c'est là où c'est très dangereux voilà
pas fermer les comptes et ils sont pris
par moment mais mais mais moi je préfère
j'ai plus confiance en la justice de mon
pays que dans des décisions arbitraires
de google
puis je vais enregistrer un truc quand
même c'est que
si on met sa carte d'identité sa photo
son numéro de passeport et tout pour
remplir son profil facebook ou twitter
ça veut dire qu'on est voilées et
arrimées et ses empreintes digitales
non mais c'est à dire qu'on donne tout
ça à google ben voilà il ya aussi un
problème ça pose un problème par rapport
à la cnil parle on est quand même un
pays de liberté vous voulez que google
après brasse toutes ces informations et
en face je ne sais pas quoi eh ben je ne
suis pas sûr merci parce que tout rien
n'est simple et c'est bien pour ça que
cette émission existe pour pouvoir
échanger des points de vue et
éventuellement en changer merci à tous
et point de vue revient bien sûr lundi
même heure même endroit très bon week
end